[Musique]
je suis pas persuadé que s'il faut le
voir dans ce sens là puisque la culture
assure aussi revenir sociale est là sur
beaucoup de choses
et puis une ouverture d'esprit tolérance
etc donc oui c'est très très compliqué
en ce moment une production de
spectacles ça se normalement ça se pense
au moins sur deux ans le temps de faire
les budgets les demandes de subventions
les recherches de coproduction ou de co
réalisation de salles
alors on est plutôt sur du 3 ans minimum
puisque déjà tous les spectacles du
premier confinement qui ont été reportés
ont bouquet un peu les programmations et
les salles aujourd'hui se retrouvent en
plus emmener dans des considérations
terrible le travail je pense ne sera
jamais fait pour rien on pourra
l'utiliser d'une manière ou d'une autre
maintenant il faut réussira à passer le
cap et et se dire que oui on crée
quelque chose en ce moment mais que si
ça se trouve demande jouera pas platon
jouera pas après demain non plus
peut-être que ce sera pas dans un an ou
dans deux peut-être on va probablement
se dirigent aussi vers des spectacles de
rue et puis des formes déambulatoire des
formes en plein air en tout cas qui
devrait être plus facile à mettre en
place
on espère